We have an interesting question on our Quiz,
where the majority was wrong.
It’s about convolutions and the difference
between invariance and equivariance.
Translational or shift invariance means that
irrespectively of the position of a cat, the
output of the convolution operation is the
same.
Which it isn’t since the feature map still
reflects the original position.
So this is actually equivariance because when
the position of the cat changes, the output
changes in the same way, reflecting shift.
And with the sliding kernel, this is exactly
what happens.
So convolutions are not shift invariant, but
equivariant.
If you got this wrong, it’s okay because
these words are used interchangeably in language
(except of highly mathematical contexts).
Please mind that the question asks about the
convolution only.
It was the next day’s trick question inquiring
about the CNN as a whole.
While convolutional layers do not make the
CNN shift invariant but only equivariant,
it takes spatial pooling layers to make it
approximately shift invariant
by pushing information that was far away,
into approximately the same spot.